6 24 on your friday morning hey how
about taking the motivation ball and
running with it i mean that literally
there's a proud mom a couple of kids
down at the macaw steam academy in
henderson and she's fired up in a good
way
crystal dunning told me about the pe
teacher that rita goldstein and the
before school activity she started
almost 20 years ago called desert
trackers crystal says kids crowd around
the school gate at 8 30 every morning so
they can get in and start running laps
until the bell rings for classes to
start
those laps are recorded on a card by
parent volunteers
with celebratory cowbell rings for every
kid who racks up 10 miles in laps
crystal says some kids walk and chat
with friends while others run their
little hearts out she says the kids are
not just learning about physical fitness
that she sees them learning that they
can do anything if they set their mind
to it
there you go on any given morning you
might see fifth graders walking hand in
hand with pre-k kids uh so they don't
get run over of course other kids that
stop to help classmates who maybe
stumble and fall when they're running
around so if you know something that's
cool at school let us know head over to
eightnewsnow.com you'll find cool at
school under the community tab or just
send us an email coolantschool
eightnewsnow.com and one more thing to
highlight the fact that ms goldstein's
been doing this for 20 years there's one
kid who likes to show off kind of a back
in the day plaque that shows his dad was
a desert tracker at macaw wow 20 years
ago wow
that's good stuff it's a small town i
love that stuff yeah i mean you know you
you always say in vegas you hardly run
into any natives well they're around
here oh for sure you know the
motto for reno is the biggest little
city in the world i think vegas is the
littlest big city in the world isn't
that the truth she's helping them get
around